do you remember the exact date you came
to Los Angeles I do actually September
18 2012 was the day I took off from
Chicago and landed it was a big
transition I had an awesome life in
Chicago I had a good job I had a great
relationship and it was just one of
those things where it was kind of that
Now or Never
breaking moment where and I'm someone
that's like you got to take a risk or
else you may regret it the rest of your
life I'd rather take a big challenge a
big risk and fail than to never do it
and live my whole life just wondering
what if so luckily I had the support of
people that were close to me family and
friends and pushed me to do it in the
most positive way which is really really
beneficial in this type of situation
especially coming from where I was like
it wasn't like I was very very happy
back in the Midwest but there was like
we talked about there's just something
missing and this is what I want to do so
in order to do it full time had to make
a movie there Easter West and I'd take
sunshine year-round when I can and so
you had like a nine-to-five job and yeah
I was an accountant
yeah yeah benefits all that good stuff
it was kind of you know same thing wake
up Jim that's a plug to tell everyone
that I go to the gym obviously and then
go to go to work but you know working
eight hours a day and you find out half
the time as I'm writing sketches or
writing this or researching how to
actually possibly make the jump or going
on auditions for whatever it may have
been TV shows commercials in Chicago and
it just got to the point where my
hobbies my my hobbies my
extracurriculars where you know they
were taking over what I was actually
getting paid to do so it's just kind of
that breaking point where just got to do
it it it's the right choice yeah do you
remember was there like a day that you
let's say you went to lunch and
something triggered in your mind you're
like I can't go back to that desk no I
will tell you the story okay you're
gonna this is very vague weird
references I really really wanted to see
Snow White and the Huntsman really okay
that's what shocks you that movie was
that was that was the impetus for you
know this is what I remember it was
early
summer you know what I'm gonna rephrase
that sure sure I went with someone that
really wanted to see Snow White in the
Huntsman I'm Katy and I actually really
wanted this okay and it was just kind of
that night where we got to talking and
it was one of those types of you know
moments in the roller-coaster life that
is the entertainment industry that
things were going really well and it was
just kind of that push to like you got
to do it now or you're never gonna
you're never gonna feel fulfilled you're
never gonna be content so it's like
let's do it so three months later I
moved Wow so did you were planning it
out then obviously like giving there two
weeks yeah I gave and you know it was
one of those things I was always
subconsciously in the back of my mind
type thing put in my back pocket improv
term anyways so that's sorry so I kind
of always was saving up a little bit
just in case because I wanted to come
out and give it a hundred percent you
know not get into that rut that I was in
Chicago I was working nine to five could
only do it half the time like I wanted
to commit everything to it
so it was like you said I from that
moment on I was planning for the fall so
it gave me you know whatever that time
for most 3-4 months yeah I gave my two
weeks notice my job was they were the
best they're meeting tomorrow go to them
for all your audio video audio-visual
and technology beads meeting tomorrow
calm they were great even to the point
where they're like for some reason you
get you get sad out there you can come
on back so that I mean having that
behind you is great but yeah planned it
out accordingly luckily I had my good
friends still living out here stayed
with him for the first week or two till
I found my own place and then here we
are you said previously you came in with
three suitcases oh yeah so that was kind
of a you know I had a nice place in
Chicago had all my stuff there and it
was ships son of some of it back home to
Ohio it's my mom which she was not happy
about and then put some of it in storage
just in case and then get rid of some of
it you know no one wanted my stuff and
like I had cool things anyways back then
now but yeah and then it was pack up
just what I need because it was
September so the holidays hit so it was
like I was back and forth a little bit
back to Midwest for Thanksgiving and
around Christmas and New Year's
you know so finally like early 2013 is
when I really felt like I was here on
September 18 2012 when you were sitting
in that Airport waiting to go through
the checkpoint and you know have your
baggage service or whatever they were
gonna do was there like this twinge of
like what am I didn't you have any kind
of moment like that like what am i doing
right now you know what I didn't have it
until I landed because I went with
somebody to the airport meant a lot to
me so it was a very supportive like you
know go get him who's Louis Gossett jr.
Clutton oh is that him now who's in Rudy
anyways the Rudy clap at the end I'm
sorry I just screwed up whoever you know
that was what it was like it was very
positive moment but then when I landed
here there's land LAX at 11:30 at night
with three bags getting my rental car
driving up the 405 learning that you put
the in front of all of the numbers of
the freeway learning to call it a
freeway instead of an expressway all
that just added up to like holy you know
crap what are we doing in an inn kind of
a crazy sense to go from like that
comfortable life where I'm you know
everyone from high school to college is
grade school was all the way around you
awesome support system to basically
starting over and being you know by
yourself again out this way it was scary
but like I said I didn't hit it until I
got here so I got on that shuttle to get
my rental car you started to feel like
no I never second-guessed it but it was
almost like that you know your your gut
drops a little bit a little you know
whatever that's a negative one
butterflies for the positive one just
those feelings of this is it like I did
it like the hard part of going through
the transition and getting here is over
now comes the hard part of trying to
make a life out here just beginning so
but that's subsided once I got into my
rhythm and got my place and hit the
ground running that kind of I'll mail it
out and then taking the flip side of
that was then there a moment where you
were let's say you got out of an auntie
maybe your first one here where you were
like this this was definitely meant to
happen I'm glad I did this
yeah it was it was I would say what came
actually right around the January time I
auditioned for my first feature film
lead role in a feature and then I got
the callback I remember I got the
callback and it was on Super Bowl Sunday
and I'm a huge football fan go Browns
Super Bowl 2016 anyways now that's a lie
they're not gonna make it this year I
wish but I just remember that and going
back to the callback and it was like
four hours long before the Super Bowl
because they were well aware of that and
then I got a phone call like a week
later that said that I got it
are you willing you know do you have you
know we're shooting for X amount of days
a few hours away etc etc and that was
kind of my first big time experience on
a sad and I was one of the leads in it
and it was it's called black water
vampire just a fun little horror film
and through that and through those
connections I've made friendships and it
was the best experience and it was just
like this is awesome you know it was
just one of those things there's like
these these are the moments that I still
remember to this day like filming this
and making these friends so there's a
camaraderie when you get into that
little even if it is independent but you
get into that little niche there is
there's just everyone's in it together
everyone has that in the same
up-and-down struggles and it's it was
fun so that was kind of my like happy
lightbulb moment when you got that call
back you felt like well when I got the
call that I got it cuz the call back
there was some dude there look just like
me both wore black t-shirts was black
t-shirt day at the callback apparently
Chad maybe I'm probably there everyone's
name Chad out here that looks like me
every blonde guy chatter Tyler and so
yeah but then a couple you know week or
so later I got the call and it was
awesome got paid to make a movie it's
kind of like the dream
you